-Thank you, thank you,
thank you so much!
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
We are here from Studio 6A
in New York City!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for being here.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, it's been five days
since the election was called,
and President Trump
still has no plans to concede.
Pretty soon,
we're going to need
Vladimir Putin
to stage an intervention.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ] "Look, it
actually isn't my birthday.
We --
We're worried about you."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Yeah, we could be working
on the pandemic or the economy,
but instead, we had to lure
Trump out of the White House
like a cat
burrowed under the couch.
[ Laughter ]
Ss, ss, ss, ss, ss, ss!
Trump's pretty much refusing
to leave the house.
He's basically turning into
the old man from "Up."
[ Laughter ]
"I should've put helium
in these balloons.
Why --
Why did I choose water?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, yesterday,
a reporter asked
President-elect Biden
about Trump's refusal to concede
and what it means
for the country,
and here's what he had to say.
-I just think it's an
embarrassment, quite frankly.
-Trump heard that and was like,
"That's what you thought
was embarrassing?"
[ Laughter ]
"A porn star sued me."
"What about when I tossed
paper towels like free throws
at the hurricane victims?
This is embarrassing?
Okay. Okay."
That's right, Biden called Trump
an embarrassment.
Then he left the podium
and spent 20 minutes
trying to find
the opening in the curtain.
[ Laughter ]
"You gotta be kidding me."
But it's been a pretty rough
couple of weeks for Trump.
Has there been
any good news for him?
-NBC News
has projected President Trump
as the winner
of the state of Alaska.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-When the news broke,
Steve Kornacki was like,
"You woke me up for this?!"
[ Laughter ]
"It's three electoral votes!"
Trump needs like 63
electoral votes, and he got 3.
It's like asking your friend
for 20 bucks,
and they're like,
"I have a Canadian loonie."
[ Laughter ]
But Trump appreciated
the victory.
Today, he said,
"I want to thank Alaska
and their leader, Queen Elsa."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is interesting.
Most Republicans
haven't congratulated Biden
on his win,
but they have been talking
to his good friend,
Democratic Senator Chris Coons.
Listen to this.
-What are they telling you
behind the scenes?
-Um -- [ Chuckles ] -- bluntly,
that they accept that --
I mean they call me to say,
you know, "Congratulations.
Please convey my well wishes
to the President-elect,
but I can't say that
publicly yet."
[ Laughter ]
-Is this the third grade?
It's like,
"Can you tell Emily
that I have a crush
on her friend Ruby?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, assuming Trump
does leave office,
the intelligence community
is worried that he might reveal
some of the country's
most classified secrets,
possibly in exchange for favors.
It's already not a great sign
that the White House
Domino's guy is like,
"I know some things."
[ Laughter ]
"I've seen some things."
Yeah, America's gone
from thinking,
"How could he not read
intelligence memos?"
to, "Thank God he didn't read
intelligence memos."
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't worry, though.
You know the Pentagon
probably made stuff up
just to see if he was listening.
It's like, "Sir, this is
highly classified, but at night,
the Natural History Museum
comes alive."
[ Laughter ]
"What?!"
"Shh! Just don't tell."
Speaking of Trump's life
after the presidency,
here's something that should
make him feel a little better.
-President Trump could land
a $100 million book deal
about his time
in the White House.
"The New York Post" reports
the President has been bombarded
with offers for book
and TV deals.
The White House
has not commented.
-$100 million.
When he heard that, Trump didn't
just concede, he quit.
He's like, "I'm out.
It's 100 mil."
Meanwhile, Melania was like,
"Just when I thought I was out,
he pulls me back in."
[ Laughter ]
$100 million is a lot,
'cause you know Trump's
just gonna print out
all his tweets
and staple them together.
"Done. Pay me.
There you go.
There's my book."
[ Laughter ]
In the meantime,
I read the Trump administration,
though, wants to make
the U.S. citizenship test
more difficult so it's harder
to become a citizen.
They even had President Trump
try it out,
but I think they might have
made it a little too tough.
I mean, check out his answers.
For example,
when asked, "To win an election,
you need the most blank,"
Trump wrote down, "Lawyers."
[ Laughter ]
Next, for the question, "Where
was the Constitution signed?"
Trump wrote down "Four Seasons
Total Landscaping."
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
Not a good start.
Next up, for,
"What is the U.S. motto,
which can be found
on the dollar bill?"
Trump wrote,
"Nobody out-pizzas the Hut."
[ Laughter ]
So close.
[ Chuckles ]
Next up, for, "What did the
Declaration of Independence do?"
Trump put "Separated Harry
and Meghan from England."
I mean --
[ Laughter ]
Why would he keep taking
the test if he's --
But, up next,
"If the president
and vice president
can no longer serve,
who becomes president?"
Trump put down
"Colonel Sanders."
[ Laughter ]
Next up, it says, "What does
the president's cabinet do?"
Trump said, "Hold
the president's snacks."
I mean, at this point,
he should stop taking the test.
Why would they even have him --
But he continued
to answer more questions.
[ Laughter ]
For the question, "Who do we
thank on Veterans Day?"
Trump somehow wrote, "Doctors
who take care of animals."
That's not veterans.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Trump answered
one more question
before they took away his pen,
for, "What is
the supreme law of the land?"
He wrote, "Eat, tweet, repeat."
There you go.
Actually he did better
than I expected.
Some business news.
I saw that Chipotle is opening
its first-ever
digital-only restaurant,
where customers have to order
ahead and pick up their food.
I'm just afraid,
because of these changes,
eating Chipotle
will no longer feel
like an authentic
Mexican experience.
[ Laughter ]
When the cashier calls out,
"Steak burrito for Greg!"
a lot of customers will be like,
"Whoa! How did you know?"
[ Laughter ]
Here's some more tech news.
Uber is launching a new feature.
Check this out.
-Uber is launching a new service
to try to attract
more customers
during the pandemic.
The new option
is called Uber Reserve.
Customers can now reserve rides
up to 30 days in advance,
and they can pick their favorite
driver for the trip.
-Who has a favorite Uber driver?
[ Laughter ]
It's like having a favorite
subway conductor.
Now Uber drivers are gonna be
the ones thinking,
"I hope this guy
doesn't murder me."
[ Laughter ]
Also, 30 days?
Who's like, "Okay.
I'm gonna be drunk in Brooklyn
on a street corner
30 days from right now"?
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, in Spain,
a 19-year-old climber
made it to the top
of a 660-foot crane
and then decided
to hang out naked.
Here's the photo.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone on the street below
was like, "That guy's nuts!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rim shot ]
When people told him no one
wants to see his testicles,
he was like, "In Spain,
it's actually pronounced
'tethicles.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]